ja letztlich hat sich eine premiere da
habe ich bei open mind super
youtube-kanal unbedingt abonnieren ein t
shirt bestellt und mit bitcoins bezahlen
ging ziemlich easy wer die kripo währung
bitcoin anfang des vergangenen jahres
gekauft hatte konnte einen bitcoin ende
des jahres 2017 für den neuen zehnfachen
wert weiterverkaufen
doch dann brachen die kurse ein aber
fest steht auf jeden fall crypto
währungen sind im alltag angekommen und
sind in der wirtschaft und auf dem welt
finanzmarkt ernst zu nehmen welche
technologien stecken dahinter und wird
es bald wohl eine globale crypt
bewährung geben
das alles und noch viel mehr jetzt in
kriegs und science fiction herzlich
willkommen
ja ihr habt euch dieses thema bei
whatsapp gewünscht und vielen dank dafür
wenn ihr bei whatsapp und jetzt auch mit
den anderen messengern facebook
messenger instagram kilogramm dabei sein
wollt ans erfahrt ihr und mitmachen
wollt ihr bei klicks um das er fragt er
am ende des videos kurz gesagt sind clip
bewährung digitale zahlungsmittel und
haben bis auf wenige ausnahmen eins
gemeinsam sie basieren auf der
technologie namens blog chain übersetzt
datenblock ketten
es ist eine art digitales register oder
kassenbuch dass alle transaktionen
aufzeichnet also sowas wie teilnehmer
hat die summe xy an teilnehmerinnen b
gesendet blog janes kann man quasi als
eine art technische handelsplattform
bezeichnet die die teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmer von transaktionen
unabhängiger macht und es gibt viele
vorteile
beispielsweise ist es für alle
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer
transparent zudem sind blogs dezentral
dass einer der wichtigsten vorteile
das bedeutet dass staatliche
institutionen wie die zentralbank
beispielsweise nicht in das system
eingreifen können zudem sind sie
fälschungssicher und an 24 stunden
sieben tage die woche für jeden offen
und verfügbar
die demokratisierung des finanzwesens
ist damit realität geworden crypto
währung werden von computern nach
wirklich komplizierten formeln berechnet
mining bezeichnet die elektronische
erschaffung des zahlungsmittels kaufen
kann man bitcoins an einer der vielen
bitkom börsen mit ganz herkömmlicher
wäre übrigens wenn man bitcoins usw
besitzt kann man damit in immer mehr
internet shops dienstleistungen oder
güter wie bei open mind zum beispiel
unbedingt abonnieren kaufen genauso aber
auch finanzmarktgeschäfte durchführen
erfunden wurde dieses konzept einer
digitalen währung übrigens 2008 und zwar
von einem software entwickler mit dem
pseudonym
sagt uschi nakamoto niemand weiß wer
wirklich dahinter steckt es gab gerüchte
dass der tesla chef elon musk sein
könnte doch der dementierte die gerüchte
ja bitcoin ist wohl das bekannteste
cocteau geld aber mittlerweile ist davon
die schon die zweite und dritte
generation am start der gibt es währung
wie kawano tron oder crypt bewährung
gelten vor allem für viele jüngere
anlegerinnen und anleger als alternative
zu gold anleihen oder aktien
doch als anlegerinnen und anleger auf
dem markt gibt es ganz andere kriterien
zu beachten und zwar weil so schnell
gehandelt wird beispielsweise was die
steuer angeht steuerfrei können so
genannte veräußerungsgewinne einbehalten
werden wenn man bitcoins eine lange
längere zeit als ein jahr hält wenn sie
dagegen innerhalb einer kurzen frist
kauft und verkauft muss die erträge
versteuern und auch viele technologie
start ups finanzieren durch diese
digitalen münzen geschäftsmodell und so
gibt es weltweit bereits mehr als 1.500
crypto währung aber warum kann man
einfach so geld machen warum wird privat
hergestelltes geld überhaupt akzeptiert
dazu muss man sich vor augen führen wie
normales geld funktioniert die basis ist
nämlich total simpel vertrauen
solange die menschen vertrauen das sie
für ihr geld waren und dienstleistungen
in einem bestimmten wert erhalten
funktioniert das system alle haben sich
quasi darauf geeinigt diese währung zum
beispiel den euro oder den dollar zu
akzeptieren allerdings ist ein solches
system empfindlich heutzutage gibt es
notenbanken dieses system kontrollieren
um den wert zu erhalten
in den zwanziger jahren hat das zum
beispiel in deutschland gar nicht
funktioniert am ende hat dort ein laib
brot mehr als achtung 100 milliarden
marke kostet das vertrauen war dahin
geld kann man übrigens auch selbst
machen und das spielt vertrauen auch
eine rolle zum beispiel mit einem
schuldschein wenn ich auf ein stück
papier schreiben das ich max 100 euro
schulde und das unterschreibe habe ich
eine art geld ich bürger mit meinem
namen dafür dass dieses stück papier 100
euro wert ist wenn es mir aber jetzt
wirtschaftlich schlecht geht dann wird
dieses papier auch weniger wert denn die
leute zweifeln daran vertrauen dass sich
das auch bezahlen kann
es ist also eigentlich ganz simpel wie
geld von
trainiert und bei crypto währung wird
das vertrauen durch die technologie
hergestellt aber wir haben anfang
mitbekommen habt ist dieses vertrauen
auf schwankungen unterlegen deshalb wird
immer wieder diskutiert ob es eine
strengere regulierung von krippe
währungen geben soll die deutsche bank
beispielsweise fordert dass
finanzbehörden in deutschland und
weltweit jedenfalls sind sich
diesbezüglich also der regelung zum
umgang mit clip bewährung nicht einig in
deutschland ist es sagen so dass kein
datenaustausch zwischen den börsen für
coop bewährung und den finanzbehörden
stattfindet so können behörden den
handel mit krupp bewährung nicht direkt
nachvollziehen wie etwa käufe und
verkäufe eines aktiendepots bei der
banken hat sich ja bereits die zweite
generation der krypto währung
angesprochen
es gehört wohl dazu und auch hier lassen
sich virtuelle münzen von a nach b
überweisen genau wie beim bitkom
doch das ist mehr als ein reines
zahlungsmittel ist ist gekoppelt an
sogenannte smart contract also eine art
intelligenter verträge die erfüllt
werden wenn es definierte kriterien also
wenn die eintreten beispielsweise kann
ein solcher smart contract das grundbuch
von immobilien abbilden heißt also im
klartext nicht nur der kaufpreis für ein
haus wird vom personal nach person b
ausgetauscht sondern gleichzeitig eben
auch die eigentumsrechte beider parteien
also das hat es bisher noch nicht
gegeben mit der bezahlung ist
automatisch dann das eigentum
übergegangen die währung namens esser
hatte im januar 2018 fast das 5 130
fache seines ausgabepreises er zahlt das
erzählt das kann sich natürlich schnell
wieder ändern
aber kommen wir zur dritten generation
dazu gehört zum beispiel tron ende mai
will tron dsc um plattform verlassen und
eine eigene blog chain namens maine et
veröffentlichen vor allem in asien will
tom punkt und zwar mit in game und in
app käufen auch die veröffentlichung
eigener inhalte steht auf der agenda
zudem planten auch ein dezentrales
internet an dem jeder teilnehmen kann
ohne zensur einer zentralen instanz 2027
soll die entwicklung von tron
abgeschlossen geschlossen sein
wie wird es wohl mit crypto währung
weiter gehen werden sie in der zukunft
tatsächlich das gute alte geld wie wir
es kennen komplett ersetzen
davon ist gary cohn der ex-präsident des
investmentbanking unternehmens goldman
sachs überzeugt seiner meinung nach
block chain ein riesiges potenzial nicht
aber der bitcoin selbstzitat ich denke
wir werden eine globale crypto währung
haben die die welt versteht warum dann
bin ich wirklich gespannt wenn er als
erstes neues zur crypto währung oder
blog chains und zu allen anderen themen
erfahren wollen dann endet meine
telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp wenn ihr
wollt könnt ihr euch da auch mit zehn
gramm instagram oder dem facebook
messenger mit mir verknüpfen kann
erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video täglich garantiert er
konnte dort direkt über mich in der
redaktion
prächtig so mitmachen themen vorschlagen
und so weiter und so fort einfach hier
draufklicken und zur begrüßung habe ich
ein kleines goodie und natürlich nicht
das awo mit der genau mit der blogger
vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit
dafür auch draufklicken
energieversorgung wird revolutioniert
strom vom nachbarn da geht es um den
stromhandel mit bock chains ansonsten
bis dann bleibt kann